there are some very important trends
that we need to discuss when it comes to
online video in today's grow with video
live show we're actually going to be
covering five of the huge trends you
need to be paying attention to when it
comes to growing your personal brand
growing your business or starting and
launching a youtube channel a tick tock
account instagram all of that is
happening this year plus we're going to
be talking about opportu opportunities
with monetization and i'm going to be
welcoming heather taurus and omar
alticori to discuss the need to know
information for winning with video
in
2022. all of that and more is coming up
on today's grow with video live show
[Music]
what is up sean cannell here and i am so
fired up to talk about five huge trends
that you need to be paying attention to
this year
in the online video space this is
episode
001 of the pop-up show called the growth
video live show we are weeks away from
the number one video marketing
event for building your personal brand
happening in las vegas and online and
we'll tell you a little bit more about
that later
but as we count down over the next
couple weeks we're going to be bringing
you some powerful guest speakers we're
going to be bringing you some powerful
strategies and actionable information so
that you can get an edge with video this
year make more money build your business
get more followers and i'm excited
because this particular episode is
packed full of data-backed
new trends that we got to pay attention
to if we really want to get an edge in a
changing video landscape and so we're
talking about five huge video trends you
need to know for 2022. click the like
button if you're fired up and i'm
excited to welcome to the show omar al
takori and heather taurus on the think
media team we'll get into trend number
one but omar uh what are you looking
forward to or how are you just feeling
about video in 2022
no i definitely think it's a it's a
funny reality because i got into video
like 15 years ago and just when i
thought it kind of was what it was it's
now just gone bigger and bigger and i
like to use the illustration of
of cursive when we used to learn cursive
back in school and they've actually not
you know they don't teach cursive no
more if you didn't know that which is
crazy because it took up so much time
when i was going to school but now i
believe video is a new form of
communication that more and more people
need to learn you need to learn how to
look into a lens you need to learn how
to clip on a mic to your shirt or or
what have you uh but i'm i'm i'm just so
grateful and excited to be a part uh to
play in an effort to help these people
help you learn the the art and the
communication skill of video uh but
that's what makes me so excited about it
is the ability to just help as many
people as we possibly can and that's why
i love being here at think media
and if you're just joining the show
shout us out where you're watching from
and uh good to see you from the
philippines here heather why are you
pumped on a macro level for video in
2022
i think for me when it comes to video in
2022 um it is an opportunity to have
free access to get your message out
there if you have a small business if
you have a brand if you're trying to
build something uh online you now have
access through understanding this medium
of just pressing record where you can be
reaching the right audience for free i
mean f-r-e-e is like my favorite thing
ever but it's getting over your comfort
zone it's pressing record and i'm
excited for video in 2022 because i
believe that there are more people
online right now that need what you have
and so i'm excited to jump into some of
the five of these trends that are
happening um but for me it is that you
can reach the people you want to reach
for free sean you talk a lot about how
your grandfather was a dentist and he
would be blown away by the impact that
we could have today in 2022 to reach our
target audience to reach the people we
want to reach for free using the power
of video
yeah and really the truth is that of
course there's some huge enemies that we
have to overcome that's you know
competition that's complexity
that's how do we stand out and as you
you know subscribe and stay connected to
the growth video live show we're gonna
be sharing really some tactics related
to that but i'm excited to get into this
first trend which is you know video
everywhere now i mean the first trend
before we get into some nuanced things
is is the fact that video
is really everywhere
right now right and that uh we've seen
that across social media platforms video
is becoming the dominant
form of communication here's an article
from quickframe.com and it says that
video will be the dominant communication
currency on social media that this year
video is going to crystallize as the
dominant way we communicate online we
consumed video at unprecedented levels
last year and it just continues to
increase online video is growing faster
than ever cisco reported that by 2022
online video is going to make up 82
percent
of all consumer internet traffic that's
15 times higher
than what it was in 2017 and i know it
may feel like video won't or can't
continue to grow but it is
is competition increasing yes but
consumption is as well is there still
opportunity for you yes 15 times growth
whenever i think about hey is that a
business i want to start or is that a
sector i want to be in i want to ask
myself
is the sector growing and online video
is continuing to explode and to be the
dominant
form of media across all platforms
social media is going video first web
searches for tick tock are still
skyrocketing in 2022 and it has grown
nine thousand five hundred percent over
the last five
years and we're seeing instagram go
video first tick tock of course is video
first youtube is a video first platform
linkedin is adding reels to to their uh
plethora of video opportunities and live
streaming opportunities facebook has
added reels
youtube is the second most visited
website on line
only second to google
and so video is really everywhere
now and it's really taken over so i'm
kind of just curious you know
omar heather we've had the privilege of
really being in this industry
in different ways for over 10 years now
and is video
did you predict this did you see this
happening is this what you expected and
and and what do you think about the
growth of just video across platform
what are your thoughts omar
man i honestly i i would say i thought
photo would do its own thing and video
would do its own thing and we are
finding even on instagram photographers
having to create videos around their
photos like it's
i i didn't see i would say i didn't
quite see this coming i think sean saw
it coming that's why he started think
media and he's like well this is going
to be what's nft's no video
if you want you want to talk about nfts
you're going to talk about nfts on video
um but nonetheless i didn't see it
coming but it's so crazy to see even
like what uh sean said that photo driven
platforms like instagram have really
accustomed to what people want and i
think that's just something to know that
video is everywhere is because video is
what people want and so uh something to
know is that that's what the heart
behind every platform you choose to
build on is coming from a place of the
platform giving people and audiences
what they actually want i don't know if
you've ever felt fell in to a video
trance of uh you know whether it be on
instagram or on tick tock or even on
youtube you can just look back and it's
like
dang two hours just went by what what
did i just do with my time but uh it's
insane it's insane to see all that's
happening when it comes to video
100
and another thing that we're noticing
under this trend number one out of these
five trends and also stick around until
the end of the video because we have a
bonus trend number six uh for you but uh
video is touching every part of the
customer journey and so you know you
wouldn't be here on one of our facebook
pages or um on our think media podcast
channel if you didn't understand that
video is everywhere and is important but
i want to encourage you this is such a
skill to learn because what we've
learned is that video is literally
everywhere in the customer journey
everywhere in online business video is
this live stream video is zoom for zoom
meetings video is pre-recording uh loom
l-o-o-m or a slack video a video is in
volley which is like a coaching slack
platform video is vertical video is
indirect messages uh video is inside of
our online courses our onboarding videos
our ads video is literally
everywhere and the challenge is okay how
can i learn the nuanced best practices
of video in all these different places
and of course we're going to be covering
that in subsequent shows and at our
event coming up soon in las vegas but
video is touching every part of the
journey and so if you haven't already uh
gone all in on video now is the time um
and let me know in the comments um where
are you publishing video is it just
youtube um are you on multiple platforms
and what platforms are you focusing on
the most
and
are you also using video in a lot of
other contexts do you use video for work
are you finding that you're in video
conferencing have you maybe created an
online course what are some of the maybe
the obscure or lesser known areas video
is touching your world let us know in
the comments um but trend number two is
the rise of short form
video this is massive the demand for
short form video is growing and aside
from tick tock short form video is also
popular on platforms like youtube
snapchat and instagram but friends short
form is taking over
i would really seriously be asking what
is my short form video strategy i would
seriously be asking if you haven't yet
how can i start incorporating short form
into my workflow if you're just on
youtube youtube shorts is the thing to
be thinking about but as i mentioned
earlier it's getting a little
overwhelming and that we have some tips
coming up later in this video for that
but literally there's facebook reels
linkedin reels is coming there's
instagram reels short form there's tick
tock of course there's youtube shorts
and short form video typically we're
seeing it as vertical video that's less
than 60 seconds but the world's crazy
because tick tock allows 10 minutes or
15 for some accounts five for our
official think media account instagram
reels could be 60 seconds maybe your
account's only approved for 30 seconds
regardless short form is everywhere and
friends here's what you really need to
lean in on
it is a massive opportunity for
discoverability and growth i'm talking
to some of our growth video live
speakers that one is gonna let me know
if she's able to come she grew
uh
four
10 million subscribers in four months 10
million followers in four months on tick
tock
can you imagine living in a world where
you could go from zero to 10 million
followers in four months what are we
talking about and on a much more
practical level because that's unicorn
results there are so many people in our
community getting 10 000 views 25 000
views 55 000 views by repurposing
youtube videos and putting them on
platforms like tick tock and instagram
reels so let me know have you created a
short form video yet you know the
movement of shorter lengths has
manifested itself in the advertising as
well listen to this
15 15-second tv ads
are about 75 as effective as 30-second
commercials
at half the cost
so this is you're probably not running
tv ads but think about this
here's the takeaway we have to learn how
to communicate in short form
can you tell your message have you
consolidated your message and messages
for your brand your personal brand
into as short as 15 seconds not only
that
they're they're 75 as uh effective so
your message doesn't need to be long to
be lethal
if you learn the skill of short form
video and on most social media platforms
ad placements don't allow video lengths
longer than 15 seconds so really
learning for some of us this is hard
because we're used to longer form video
and and we are
paying heavy attention at think media to
15 second or less pieces of content and
seeing how powerful they can be in a
paid ads environment in an organic
vertical video growth environment um but
let's uh let's go a little deeper on
this short form video and i'm curious
because i know you know even
we feel just like you we feel like shoot
man there's another thing to learn
um you know i prefer maybe you prefer
longer form content but friends when
when change is happening it's really
smart to redirect your sales to catch
where the wind is blowing if if there's
a stream is going to you know rather
than trying to paddle upstream against
the trends it's smart to let the current
take you into growth and revenue and
impact i'm curious heather just your
emotions around this short form movement
more things to do but also the
opportunity you see
yeah i was just gonna hit on that sean
is that you know even as a content
creator uh someone who is um actively in
video to me sometimes it does feel like
uh it's just one more thing but i think
one thing that i've discovered over the
last year or so when it comes to short
form content and seeing different types
of creators is that short form content
allows you to be massively creative you
actually you don't actually have to
dance in short form video i'm not a
dancer it's not for me but you can be
punchy and educational um i've been
studying different short form creators
who are uh using just very simple um
tweets they're just reading their tweets
you know there's so many ways that you
can be really creative in a very short
period of time and actually i love sean
that you brought up that you know
commercials that are 15 seconds really
short forms are a type of commercial for
your brand when i think about um brock
johnson and chalene johnson you know
they are creating content short form
reels and tick tock videos that are
helping people come into
their audience when i think about alex
and layla hermosi some speakers uh some
some keynote speakers at our growth
video live event you know they are
blowing up their personal brands just by
answering questions answering specific
questions and bringing people into their
world for the deeper level content so if
you're like me and you love going live
or you love making long-form content
just be thinking about the strategy of
the short form in that it can be like a
commercial for your audience and i think
what's really fun about short form video
is that you know it is you can make a
lot of it in a short amount of time one
thing that shawn and i are doing is i'm
writing out the next 20 reels that i
want to make and take doctrine shorts um
and i can make all of those in one day
versus you know when i'm thinking about
making a full-on youtube video i can
maybe make one or two um sitting down
for a session so i'm excited about the
movement of short form content um i
consume a ton of short from content i
find myself scrolling unreals all the
time
and i think it's a really great way for
us to be able to add more creativity to
what we're doing in our video creation
to grow our businesses and brands
i agree 100
and you know if you want help navigating
this online video world and some of
these newest formats uh we're gonna get
into trend three and four and five here
in just a second but i want to shout out
jessica she's already coming to growth
video live happening in vegas already
has found an awesome roommate and she's
fired up if you haven't heard about
growth video live yet check out this
quick video and then we'll be back with
the rest of the trends do you want to
get in the room with experts like gary
vaynerchuk patrick vette david vanessa
lau pat flynn chalene johnson and more
and would you like to meet hundreds of
other creative entrepreneurs just like
you well then do not miss the chance to
get around creators and business
influencers at growth video live 2022
conference you can actually lock in your
limited discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com and
take the fast track to dominating the
next decade not just with youtube but
with video go to growthvideolive.com or
click the link in this post or in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket
yeah we're so fired up for growth video
live and here's the thing as a viewer of
the grow with video live show
um we have a code for you if you want to
snag a five percent off discount of any
ticket level whether virtual or in
person just use the code gwvl
show that stands for grow with video
live
show
um in the coupon code box when checking
out at growthvideolive.com and you can
see all of the details there but i want
to keep it moving and get you these
trends um next up is trend three place
your bets on youtube tiktok and
instagram
speaking about uh you know short form
video
of course we love youtube it's
interesting talking to some of my most
influential tick tock friends again with
millions of followers they still say
that youtube is absolutely the most
valuable
subscribers it's the most valuable
platform a lot of people who
have breakout success on tick tock like
to then move that over and try to
navigate that over to if you will the
more established and if you kind of
respected solid foundation of youtube
but when i say trend three place your
bets on youtube tiktok and instagram
i am talking about in short form context
uh we have had some crazy things happen
at think media our most viewed video at
think media is a youtube short um we hit
seven million views uh nolan mult made
that video um we recently had right now
our official think media tick tock
channel
is really just repurposed content some
original content from others on the team
but if you see this
one youtube
short
got uh six
7.5 million views and is still getting
124 views per hour it's brought
something like
30 000 new subscribers into our channel
one youtube short on youtube on tick
tock we had a tick tock breakout 700 000
views repurposing some content from one
of our recent leadership retreats and so
uh the powerful thing here in trend
number three is that when creating
vertical content you can post it
multiple places so the 750 000 viewed
tick tock was also something that we
placed on instagram reels and over here
on instagram reels we are getting nine
thousand four thousand ten thousand
fifty six thousand views
and that same video was also shared uh
or will be shared as a youtube short on
our think media channel you know one of
the things we're going to be sharing
with you in this show is secrets like
just kind of our own strategies we're
we're going to start posting two shorts
a week and what we're going to do
is just look through our winners over
here and just be like okay this got 12
000 if it's on brand for our youtube
channel why not post this video as a
youtube short as well schedule upload on
the weekend good title and so uh place
your bets on youtube
on tiktok and on instagram there's other
platforms we love all the platforms but
i think that's something really to pay
attention to omar i'm curious uh i mean
you're also hip contemporary you got you
got you're on the pulse
i got a single origin coffee in my
chemist cup like right now
exactly that's that's what i mean and so
what are your thoughts as far as i mean
you have also looking at kind of what
where gen z's mindset is you know on the
emerging platforms when we're talking
about huge video trends uh what are your
thoughts on those three and maybe other
ones we should pay attention to
no i mean i think i think what's what
what i see is happening is that it's
really this merge of entertainment and
and and education
and edutainment is being merged in the
form of video and and that's why this is
really popping off because like people
are getting entertained but that's where
you can kind of separate if i if i could
just simplify kind of like the way you
can see it all so like we said video is
everywhere now uh but place your bets on
these three youtube tik tok and
instagram i would encourage you to view
social media and youtube as a service
machine and not a slot machine i'm
finding a lot of entrepreneurs are just
like their their reason for jumping on
is like i just i want to do it to cash
in quick when the reality is it's like
no you want you should want to do it so
you can just serve people the people
that are really growing fast that i find
that are building their brand and their
businesses is they're actually using
these platforms to serve and educate and
show and and document and and let people
into their business and that's how you
can actually make it work for your
uh business and brand is is by uh by
providing value to whatever platform
you're on so i just i would say that's
just one way to look at it that's kind
of like where i'm coming from like how
can i serve in shorter amount of time
you know you just got to be more
intentional with the smaller uh with
shorter videos and uh you know there's
this funny stat that like we human
beings have like shorter attention spans
than a goldfish like goldfish got like a
10 second attention span and we have
like an eight second attention span but
it's kind of like also encouraging
because now you just gotta focus on how
you can bring so much value in a short
amount of time um and
if there's ever bleed over you can
there's there's more content that you
can create and so i think i think it
just provides more opportunities and uh
wherever there's more opportunities it
allows more people to jump in and it's
it's really i'm impressed at the people
who just show up consistently and how
fast they're going in short amounts of
time and so i think it's just coming up
with strategies that allow you to be
consistent on the these platforms and
i'm excited to talk about how we can do
that for you and how we do it here at
think media yeah and some good questions
coming in here how do you search a
person on reels i don't see a search bar
for that so so the cool thing about you
know omar just touched on it you kind of
got to trust us if you haven't tried it
the organic growth because of the
algorithm specifically on instagram and
tick tock and youtube shorts
is is it's that it's not search based
it's actually algorithmic
discoverability
oftentimes based off their interest
graft meaning tick tock is studying you
and they find that you like
you like all snowboarding content i get
recommended snowboarding videos all the
time snowboarding reels or you like
business content i get recommended
business content so maybe i haven't
heard about somebody that is a coach or
has products or services or software
company and next thing you know i can
become a customer of theirs right
because it all starts with meeting them
on reels they've got a book they've got
software and so it works for any niche
it could work from entertainment
education edutainment infotainment and
so it's really not search based it's the
fact that you're creating smart content
and you're getting discovered and
growing following um with that in fact
one of the um
examples that i want to encourage you to
follow and uh you can even learn from
but if you didn't know we launched an
account called official think media and
so
we finally not just my personal brand
but we now have a team brand instagram
account highly recommended official
think media you can kind of watch what
we're doing over there and it's a it's
not just me but you can learn more from
heather and omar the think media team
but i want to encourage you yes do we
have a pre-existing following absolutely
could we like email our newsletter and
let them know about this yes so it's not
like we started from scratch but here's
the thing we did start from scratch
i mean we started at zero
and i haven't shouted it out much or
even at all on my my uh instagram it has
grown organically but here's what's also
crazy
the views on the reels of this account
are better than my personal account
which is a little bit older and so we're
getting eleven thousand ten thousand
twelve thousand views eight thousand
fifteen thousand this isn't search based
this is this is a brand new account on
its way to ten thousand followers
leveraging mostly short form vertical
video and the same is true if you're on
tick tock check us out at official think
media on tick tock and so
i want to encourage you it's not you
don't think of it as search you think of
it more as creating the right content
that would get you in front of your
ideal audience and the discoverability
here and then one other quick question
as we go into the next trend uh delvin
says why not post all of your reels on
youtube
in our case for some that might be smart
to do in our case we're asking a couple
things
you know sometimes i talk like heavy
personal development and less youtube
and that might not quite be on brand for
our think media channel
so we just is we i would ask does this
reel honor the promise that our youtube
channel has made if it does i would
argue don't potentially put a limit on
it
two
because think media in our case has
built such a
consistent promise of long-form
longer-form high-value content five
uploads a week
uh my new goal is to get to seven
uploads a week two shorts a week and to
just put the best of the best there so
to test the short form content elsewhere
um and then and that's why not do all of
them if i test five a week what are the
winners and especially now we can go
back a couple months and we're gonna
schedule out the next
we're gonna schedule out the next uh
eight weekends
all at once uh when it comes to the
winners of our vertical videos in the
past so that's a little bit of insight
into our strategy smash like if you're
enjoying the uh value in the grow with
video live show today we're talking
about five trends we actually have a
bonus six trend that you got to pay
attention to in online video this year
uh trend three was place your bets on
youtube tick tock and instagram but
trend number four is new monetization
opportunities
my friends
it is a fact now that being a content
creator is the fastest growing small
business type
and the data is in for this and i know
that in a world of
rising inflation and i know that it also
this this seems crazy in our mindsets we
go oh man there's no way this thing can
last you know if things if the if the
bottom really falls out what's going to
happen to all the content creators well
the smart content creators
which we call content entrepreneurs the
smart youtubers
which we call youtube preneurs
are understanding that no matter what
happens to the economy e-commerce is not
going away
online shopping is not going away
if you've created multiple income
streams
what has really just happened is that
entertainment and education qvc which
was once on tv and still is has moved
online and is also amazon live like my
friends that are making bank doing
amazon live streams you probably even
know amazon live was the whole thing we
didn't even we're talking video goes
deep
what smart content creators are
understanding is that this is where
people are getting their information
this is where people are making buying
decisions this is where people are
shopping and people are going to shop no
matter what
and so is there potentially tough times
ahead absolutely but the trends and the
growth of e-learning and e-commerce and
advertisers paying you through the tick
tock creator fund and through youtube ad
revenue it's just here
it's happening it's not going away
and it's the fastest growing type of
small business and so this next decade
is going to be the best decade on the
crater economy there's now two million
global creators making six figures
from one study from signal fire this is
the rapid rise of being a content
creator is financially lucrative
and technically creators come into the
category of small businesses
okay and that's actually how i want you
to be thinking if you haven't started
thinking and we're going to go really
deep on this at growth video live jay-z
said it best i'm not a businessman i am
a business
man
right
you're building the business of you
you're building your personal brand
you're diversifying your personal brand
across multiple platforms and so there's
massive new opportunities sponsored
influencers are worth 8 billion dollars
today
forbes predicted that just this year
alone there's going to be 5x growth in
the revenue flowing into the crater
economy
now that didn't maybe hit as hard as it
should have you may need to set down
your chick-fil-a milkshake and pull your
car over because ultimately
5x growth on an already multiple billion
dollar industry in just the next nine
months is insane i hope you've hitched
your wagon to this gravy train i hope
that you've hitched your horse to this
apple cart i hope i can come up with a
third analogy on this just kidding you
know uh in terms of this this is real
and i mean i i'm not trying to be hype
filled about it it's this is just what
is happening these are the huge trends
that are happening in online video right
now and so it's a smart bet to be
leaning in on this 22 000 youtube
creators have more than a million
subscribers
and here's what i want to encourage you
with i know it can really feel like man
it's too late to get in the game
man it's too late to start and break out
man there's so much competition but i
just kind of have one insight for you
that
will prove
uh
how much opportunity there is and how
big the world is and how diversified
audiences are
you probably didn't know there's 22 000
youtube creators that have a million
subscribers and you probably can't list
10 of them
right like you might not even follow
anybody that has a million subscribers
because you like more niche hobby
specialized content that's the world
we're living in seth godin calls it the
long tail there's so much opportunity in
the long tail and we're learning this
with even some of our speakers at growth
video live for example we have patrick
bett david coming let me know if you've
ever heard of pbd from valuetainment
he's
the number one entrepreneur channel on
youtube over three million subscribers
one of my favorite business leaders
content experts his book the next five
moves so pbd's one of our speakers
i've talked to other speakers they go i
don't even know who that is
right well 3.5 million people do right
alex ramose is another one of our
speakers he sold 100 000 copies of his
book 100 million dollar offer with no
advertising his youtube channel grew by
a hundred thousand subscribers in the
last couple months you've probably never
heard of him
and so
here's my point we have thousands of
students in our video regular academy
and whatnot that you've never heard of
that have six figure businesses they're
making 300k a year some have million
dollar businesses some are making an
extra 10k a year the long tail is so
huge when you start to see how big the
world is
how
how big small groups of niche passions
are people that want to learn about a
specific thing this is why gary
vaynerchuk you know one of our keynote
speakers wrote a book 10 years ago
called crush it why now it's time to
cash in on your passion and really
started to point
towards the opportunity to create a
youtube channel a tick tock account an
instagram account around that thing
you're passion of passionate about that
very specific thing and to build
a full-time at-home business with a
thousand true fans
it's just so real and this is what the
data is showing us 22 000 youtube
creators have more than one million
subscribers
so hundreds of thousands
have less than a million hundreds and
hundreds of thousands have five thousand
ten thousand
do you see like and and you don't know
even a fraction of them your neighbor
might be youtube famous but that's just
joe oh yeah i didn't realize joe is on
this is the world
and it's not slowing down it's only
speeding up
but you gotta go all in to learn you
know the strategies and ways of making
money so sites like memberfold buy me a
copy live library libra pay
are
new means of content creators generating
revenue and of course you may have heard
a lot of you could write ebooks make
online courses
patreon
twitch
uh getting paid for uh tips all kinds of
super chats and super stickers and
channel memberships on youtube uh it
makes your head spin
but friends there's so much opportunity
and that's really trend number three is
there's new monetization opportunities
happening all the time the shorts fun
the tick tock crater fun and so this is
going to be one of the biggest topics we
go really deep on um at groweth video
live in fact uh if you haven't heard
about it yet you know we have anthony
o'neil speaking of jasmine star
patrick about david gary vaynerchuk
what's fascinating is these individuals
are also really the best of the best in
the industry but they're doing
different way they have different
business models they have actual service
businesses they are best-selling authors
they run an insurance company they have
photography businesses they have diet
plans and health and fitness brands they
have all kinds of different things so if
you really want to learn
in 2022 and getting set up for this next
decade and how to build a high impact
and high profit online business with
video you know across platforms then
this is the event for you and what's
cool is you can attend virtually or you
can come in person as well we have
limited seating obviously in las vegas
uh but it because you're a growth video
live show watcher i want to encourage
you gv gwvl show is the promo code to
get five percent off um and uh you can
learn more about everything at
growwithvideolive.com
but i've got trend number five for you
and bonus number six i wanna hear more
from heather and omar i want to answer
some of your questions but heather is
going to tell us a little bit more about
if you're just hearing about growth
video live let me know if you've heard
about it yet because you know this is
biggest event of the year maybe in the
online video space and you might be like
i haven't even heard of it kind of
speaks to how big the world is right so
let me know if you've heard about it and
then heather uh let us know some of the
details about this event
yes and someone was asking you can go to
growwithvideolive.com if you want to
secure that ticket the code right now is
grow g w v l show and that will get you
uh that discount and when you get over
to that page you enter in all your
information enter that code and when you
add it to your cart it will apply that
discount for you so that's how you get
that discount to the event and we have
some amazing speakers like sean just
said and we actually just added new
speakers this week as well you're going
to be hearing from aaron on demand who
went from a content creator to a ceo and
she's growing her business gonna be
sharing how she was able to do that
we've got evan carmichael who has been
able to explode on youtube sharing other
people's content he's gonna be helping
us uh with that and then also anthony
o'neil that sean just mentioned who was
actually a part of the ramsey family if
you know dave ramsey who's part of that
dave ramsey family and has really grown
his personal brand helping people
through video and podcasting so you can
join us live in las vegas hello who's
excited for las vegas uh live in las
vegas for uh may 23rd and 24th um and we
have a bonus day on the 25th for our
platinum day uh participants you can
join us at the m resort and casino and
what i love so much about this hotel
first off like isn't this hotel cool
omar i mean look how cool this hotel is
the m casino is so cool and uh omar
we're gonna be having a pool party did
you know that a pool party at the end
resort
like right there like right there
that's gonna be fun no i'm excited it's
kind of funny because it's like this is
our backyard a lot of us here at think
media uh we're based in las vegas uh but
no it's going to be such a vibe and
i'm just i'm excited to meet a lot of
the people who are in our comments or a
part of our community um but yeah you
definitely want to look into those
different um you know ways of
signing up for this event because a
special group of people are only going
to be able to come to that vip party at
the polls
it's going to be so much fun we're going
to have a poolside party there there's
going to be so much networking available
for you we've really we've been to
hundreds of events ourselves and one of
the things we know that our community
you think media community have been
asking for is opportunities to connect
with other entrepreneurs other uh people
who are growing their personal brand
with videos we're gonna be giving uh so
many opportunities for you to be able to
network with like-minded entrepreneurs
which to me is the best rooms to be in
when you are in a room with people that
you can totally vibe with because they
understand what you're doing and we are
offering in person as well as virtual
experience options we understand that
some people right now don't want to
travel or can't travel so you have that
option for the virtual but if you can
get in the room i want to encourage you
to get in the room for grow with video
live 2022. it's going to be a
unbelievable experience you're going to
walk away with tangible and actionable
steps for how to be growing your
business from top leading industry
experts and you can use the promo code
gwvlshow to get that five percent off at
growwithvideolive.com but sean i'm
excited to hear the next stat or the
next uh part about video
yes we've been covering uh video is
everywhere we've been covering short
form video youtube tick tock instagram
you got to place your bets there new
monetization opportunities uh but trend
number five before we get into our bonus
trend of uh trend number six uh we have
is video podcasting video podcasting
and this is a big one and i really want
you to seriously consider
how you could incorporate video
podcasting into your strategy and so you
know video podcasting um is interesting
because some of the trends we're seeing
even among youtube is that youtube is
making moves right now to incorporate
podcasting into their platform maybe
there'll be an rss feed there as well
but what is a video podcast well
ultimately a video podcast
we know audio podcasting of course you
can upload on apple and on spotify but
you know even spotify allows you to
upload a video podcast
and you can have that feed as well uh
not only that you can of course go on
android and there's a litany of
platforms and different tools that allow
you to broadcast your message multiple
places but the power of video podcasting
is simply turning on the camera and
doing a solo round or interviewing
guests using tools like zoom or stream
yard and having an interview show and
also creating that video asset that
allows you to distribute your podcast on
youtube and video podcasting is a
massive trend and one of our speakers
pat flynn
at girl video live uh years ago said you
know i i really like audio and he's got
a really strong point here i like audio
only because it allows you to focus you
know on audio only and it allows it to
just be kind of that experience but i
was just at another event with him and i
said pat what do you do you still have
the same views about audio only in
podcasts and he said no my view is
different video is too important it's
too big um and
another one of our uh friends kerry
newoff who has a kind of a faith-based
leadership podcast again he interviews
all his guests on zoom and he just
started throwing those videos on youtube
it wasn't even his main point his main
point was audio but now he has over 10
000 subscribers some of his videos have
gotten 2 000 views some have gotten 75
000 views over time because youtube's a
search engine because you can actually
you know publish your content not just
an audio tapping into a whole nother
vertical of reaching people and
spreading your message further but you
also can leverage video as well so i'm
actually kind of curious you know omar
is uh we would call him our resident
video podcasting expert in fact i'm
going to do a test in real time in front
of everybody i'm gonna search video
podcasting
here on uh
on youtube to see if we can find any
think media videos where's our friend
pat
yep we got pat on there we got uh here's
a think media video uh on podcast
there's heather on video podcasting
there's a there's omar showing us the
video podcasting studio and so i think
omar has 10 20 videos all ranked on
youtube if you want to learn a little
bit more on video podcasting this is a
major trend to think about this year and
omar why do you think video podcasting
offers so much opportunity for uh those
listening to today's broadcast
um i mean i think the opportunity is the
uh the opportunity to go deeper obvious
you know podcasts typically are a little
bit longer form um and you know not
necessarily have to be an hour but
definitely could be somewhere along the
lines of nine to
35 45 minutes uh here at think media
podcast we like to keep it at around 25
minutes but i think the opportunity is
for people who find themselves busy like
if you're an entrepreneur or if you have
a side hustle or you have a full-time
job and you want to start something new
here's what's so cool about video
podcasting
that i have found it is a content format
that allows you to syndicate it
10 plus different ways and let me paint
this picture real quick if you sit down
and you conduct a video podcast let's
say an interview with somebody and you
could sit down and you could do it over
online or you can do it in person but
now you have this you know 10 minute
conversation what's so cool about that
is that 10-minute conversation now gets
exported as an audio and a video so now
you have two files one goes on youtube
the audio file goes on apple podcast and
spotify
now what you can do is take moments from
that podcast
interview and upload those short you
know videos 15 seconds to up to 60
seconds and now distribute those clips
onto
tick tock instagram and youtube shorts
and in one sitting you allowed yourself
to spread out all this amount of content
and all you had to do was you know sit
down once and focus on that video and i
think this is kind of one of the best
ways to get started because it's
probably the best use of your time if
you're busy
i've seen people do this in the form of
live streaming they start a live stream
video podcast show and then from that
live stream they then it's it's up it's
live you take the audio and then you cut
out little portions and i know you've
probably seen these you know videos on
these platforms of people sitting down
talking into a mic and and and it's just
a portion of that podcast and so it's
really crazy the opportunity because
people are discovering podcasts you
probably discovered the podcast you
listen to audibly probably on youtube or
even on instagram and tick tock now
because you saw the video side of it and
then you're like okay i'm an audio
listener so then you hop on the audio
then you go work out and listen to that
podcast but you got this you discovered
that podcast on a social media platform
or youtube so i think the the
opportunity is is is in the time saving
but then and up and then uh the
discoverability of what your podcast and
how your podcast could be found
yeah so powerful and uh
ultimately video podcasting is a major
trend that we recommend uh paying
attention to this year but we do have a
bonus trend for you in just a second um
wherever you're listening or watching to
this if you've been getting value so far
though can you smash the like button and
let us know if you have a question
related to online video this year we
probably have time for one or two uh but
before we get to trend number six um i
uh do want to remind you that uh there
are limited seats remaining for growth
video live online we'll be able to
accommodate
you but in person um we uh definitely
want to let you know about it check this
video out and we'll be right back with
trend number six have you heard the most
recent youtube statistics right now
being a content creator is the fastest
growing small business youtube paid
creators over 14 billion dollars in the
last year from adsense alone wow youtube
generated more revenue than netflix in
2020 and forbes said that by year end
the creator economy is going to
experience 5x growth in the next 12
months so how can you take advantage of
this opportunity to start making money
with your youtube channel and even going
full time working from home we'll show
you how at grow with video live 2022
conference just go to
growwithvideolive.com
or click the link in this post or in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket if you want to learn
the best new strategies for getting
views on youtube making money online and
crushing it on social media then don't
miss this life-changing event during
this two-day event you'll learn exactly
how to grow and monetize an online
business using video you're going to
learn directly from proven industry
experts like gary vaynerchuk patrick
bette david vanessa lau pat flynn
chalene johnson and more you'll meet
hundreds of other creative entrepreneurs
just like you and connect with leading
brands in our industry join us in person
in las vegas or virtually from anywhere
in the world secure your ticket at
growethvideolive.com and take the fast
track to dominating the next decade with
youtube and social media marketing go to
growwithvideolive.com or click the link
in this post or in the description to
secure your limited time discounted
ticket right now
and on top of that
if you want to grab an even
bigger discount added an additional five
percent off uh at this time there's
still early bird ticket prices so you
can get an additional five percent off
using the promo code gwvl show i want to
thank you so much for being a part of
the show today but before we get
to um our
sixth and bonus trend wanted to answer a
couple
questions here uh is the term
broadcasting in yet um
i have heard the term i don't think it's
being widely used but that would be an
abbreviated way of saying video
podcasting
and jessica that's a great question
should i do a video podcasting on the
same channel
as i do
long form what is your take on that omar
i mean i think a lot of it just comes
with your choice
in regards to how you're showing up for
your community um i i'd say you can you
know like if you plan on showing up
whether that's once um every first
friday of the month you drop a video
podcast uh on your channel sweet you
know like maybe it's once a week uh but
i i think it's it's all about like your
decision to show up consistently with it
i don't think it's all that helpful if
you're just uh you know
here and there you're popping in and
then three months goes by and so i would
say 100 that's the cool thing about
content and that's the cool thing about
marketing is that you're you're testing
and so test it out see how it works out
see if people resonate with it after you
know a couple episodes and if they don't
just you know you pull it back and you
can still shoot those video podcasts and
then just take portions of it and maybe
upload it but i think everything comes
down to experimentation and you should
totally try it out
100 i want to thank
fireside chat for the super chat today
thanks so much really appreciate you and
grateful that we have been able to help
you grow your audience and your views
explore with andy was wondering if
shorts would be monetized to the same
level as long form uh i don't think
it'll be the same level what they have
is they have a shorts crater fund
out of 7.5 million views on a short that
we got we earned around a hundred
dollars um and
if we get that many views on a uh in on
normal videos we earn thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars but
that explore with andy does not mean
that shorts are not valuable shorts are
definitely a reach an awareness and a
meet new people play because the
algorithm is so favorable to them but
it's also something to be careful with
because certain types of audiences like
different types of content there's no
doubt about it long form high value
content is a lot more lucrative when it
comes to monetization of course we'll be
unpacking those kinds of things more
uh fireside chat says wait you guys are
having an event in vegas uh take my
money i appreciate it we'd love to have
you out in fact if you've got questions
um i've got another we're gonna get to
trend six but i've got another uh
uh event that i need to get to inside of
one of our groups in just a second so i
wanna encourage you when you go to grow
at videolive.com you're going to see
different ticket levels
and at the vip level we have two days
where we have lunch and q a
with
the think team and some of our guest
speakers so if you really would want to
get into a place where you have another
level of access that's available to you
if you're a little bit further along in
your business you have more momentum you
already are
have a lot of momentum financially we
have a much kind of higher level
business mastermind level that adds a
whole third day and it's called our
platinum experience so all of those
details are at growth videolive.com but
again you can take five percent off of
any ticket or virtual which we've made
very affordable you're going to want to
get that virtual ticket before the price
goes up and the early bird discount is
over
growth video live at the time of
live streaming this recording this is
about 60 days away so uh definitely snag
an extra 5 off using the promo code and
you can check out links in the
description or the facebook post as well
as all of these details as well and in
the comments but we need to get to trend
number six and um it is this
smart creators are creating smart
systems
why is this a trend why is this one of
the huge online video trends maybe
because you're saying sean i'm a little
overwhelmed
sean how is it possible
to literally publish my content on
linkedin and tick tock in instagram and
youtube while at the same time i'm
trying to do this as a side hustle
even if you're a full-time business
owner or even a full-time content
creator already you probably feel a
sense of overwhelm with all of the
different things to do and so one of the
trends that we've been noticing
is that among the content creators that
are flourishing in a 2022 environment is
that they are feeling the demand to
create smart systems
ultimately we do not rise to
our goals we fall to our systems meaning
we can set goals like i want to dominate
video but if you don't have strong
systems so what does that mean it means
tools it means workflows it means
batching it means starting to figure out
your time management your energy
management it means understanding where
is your time best spent in each season
it means systems for generating revenue
so you can reinvest that revenue into
team members and into uh services that
could help you with video editing or
repurposing your content um because the
only way to really dominate video in
this environment is eventually you can't
do it alone and that means that robots
are going to be helping you
software that means that potentially
very affordable services are going to be
helping you i mean it could be something
like repurpose house or fiverr or
vid chops or things like that or it
means that you're also building out
eventually the skill of hiring and
leadership or collaboration and so a
huge trend when it comes to dominating
the first
five uh trends we've identified is that
you've got to create a system for this
and i want to encourage you
just simply being here on the growth
video live show and asking this question
i hope has added massive value to you
that you would be thinking about today
be thinking about tonight be thinking
about for the rest of this week as
you're laying in bed dreaming about your
online video battle plan
that you'd be thinking about also man
what are the smart systems that i need
to create
and i encourage you to go do that and
and and and crush it but if you would
say i want help
that's really the heart behind our event
grow with video live literally the best
of the best who made the mistakes who've
had to figure it out who've who've i
tried that software it wasn't good you
don't want to use that the kind of
networking that's going to be happening
in the room the kind of collaboration
that's going to be happening this is
also we're not just here to teach at our
event growth video live we're here to
learn and we're i've never seen
a speaker line up quite like this one
that uh that we are seeing come together
for growth video live and we're excited
to learn their systems what are the
latest you know tools you're using what
are the latest tactics you're using i
just had a little meeting with one of
our speakers before this for 30 minutes
i took a page in notes and it's going to
influence what i'm doing tomorrow as i'm
creating some vertical videos so if you
want access to some of that just heads
up we're here to serve you at either a
virtual level or an in-person level um
and uh you can see all of the details at
growthvideolive.com and just for the
growth video live show we're here weekly
counting down to the event grow with
video live show you can hit the like
button we'll be answering more questions
bringing on some special guests here to
help you and serve you on the journey
but also to remind you that you're not
going to want to miss literally this
historic event i have never seen this
speaker line up with gary vaynerchuk
patrick betdavid pat flynn i mean we
can't even fit everybody here on the
banner i mean we're we're doing our best
to keep up with all the speakers that
are coming and so i'm fired up and i
hope that you can join us either in
person or online growth videolive.com um
if you want to go to the next level
right now and you want more to watch
click or tap the screen to learn all
about the youtube domination framework i
want you to see this and so click or tap
the screen to watch that video right
here on youtube my name is sean cannell
from think media and the founder of grow
with video live i can't wait to see you
in the next growth video live show until
then keep crushing it keep smashing it
hit like if you got value today and we
will talk soon